- Do you think it's crazy though?
Okay, you grew up in the
South and maybe from more
humble beginnings than, obviously, now.
Like, do you think it's crazy, if like...
My husband and I talk
about this all the time
with my life. Like, in my
life, in our life, we're like
"Wow!", we came from like
nothing, and like, you know,
do you think about that? Like...
- Yeah! I come from
real humble beginnings.
- Me too!
- I think when I was 6 years
old, though, is when I heard
a voice that changed my life
forever and that was Whitney.
- "Oh!"
- And I heard the song
"The Greatest Love of All."
Such an epic song.
The lyrics are so prevalent
still today, right?
- That's literally; I love hearing that!
What were your, kind of, beginnings?
- When I moved to...
- You better be have been humble, Tony!
(laughter)
- My first...
- When I took the silver
spoon from my mouth...
(laughing)
- My favorite thing to
do, is like, go to a mall.
Um, I-I, my first... I love a mall.
- I was like, did he just say mall?
- It's a mall. It's a mall.
No, but I remember when I moved
to New York, my first show
was "Shakespheare in the
Park"-ing lot in the East Village.
(laughing)
- And we did, we did, uh...
- There it is! There it is.
- We did, uh, I'm not kidding!
We did "Taming of the
Shrew" in a parking lot
in the East Village and I rocked it.
- He said Shakespheare in the parking lot.
- It's not like a garage
band, that's like...
- No, no. We did...
- Parking lot.
- We did Shakespeare next to all the
East Village folks.
- I love that.
- It was in the mid 90's.
- (Kelly) Gosh! That's awesome!
- So, top that, Nicole!
- Alright. (laughter)